would your advice be to an 18 or 21 year
old girl who is going to start doing
only fans
the problem is is you read stories like
mine in the news oh my god she's making
three or 400k a month it's like that is
not the norm that took there's a lot
more than just shooting some videos i am
a i'll own it i am a marketing genius
like i i'm very good at what i do from a
business perspective and i am incredibly
driven
um it's there's so much more behind the
scenes and i think that there's a
falseness out there that these girls
think they're just going to get rich off
this and that that's not so other than
just being hot what what does it take to
be a successful only fans girl um well
for one i you know like i think
there's a sense in general in social
media i think there's a sense of there's
a desire for realness you know we around
so much fake everything's filter
everything's this that and i definitely
feel like one of the things that i've
played off i knew coming into this
they're not just there for boobs and
buns i mean obviously there you can get
that on twitter there was more to that
and so for me it was really building a
community around me and who i am as a
person as a wife
that was one aspect to me is maintaining
authenticity and being real not scripted
not big production just owning it i was
never afraid oh they're gonna know i'm
married they're not gonna like my
content never
fazed me
that's one thing the other thing that i
would say is
i'm very good about diversifying my
audience amongst different things like
i'm also a now ceo i'm an entrepreneur
i'm a ceo of my i made my own platform
and so i'm heavily in crypto you know
i've also not just have one one funnel
stream of income
and i think that's obviously something
important um and then also a lot of
things that i think a lot of people get
really hung up on clout you know they
get hung up on oh i need this many
followers or i need this and i've never
cared and in regards to how much money
i'm making in the amount of people i
have subscribing to me my follower
account doesn't even
you would never think
but that's just something that for me
it's never been my focus it's always
been about providing value and giving
fee you know building that community
around me as odd as it is in this
industry you would think how do you
build a community around you know that
but i have and it's it's just something
that works for me um rebecca you want to
weigh in on this no i agree with a lot
of what she said um especially for girls
trying to get into this
um you know they see her and they think
well that's the rule like
everyone that gets on only fans everyone
that
gets on instagram is going to flourish
and going to make hundreds of thousands
of dollars per month and then
you know be a billion or a millionaire
but that's also the thing too what you
said is yes you are a very intelligent
woman you said i'm going to take what
i'm making and then i'm going to invest
in a company and i'm going to create a
company off of that a lot of people they
make fast money and fast money goes as
quick as it comes right
um and so and we've seen this on youtube
as well like you blow up really fast and
then your content doesn't you don't stay
consistent with it
and you fall off and but the thing i
will say about it too is that
with social media in general you always
have to keep leveling up and there's a
certain point where it's like the how
much level up do you have to get how
much time effort
you know money all of that stuff do you
have to pour into it for that return
right what are you gonna give up are you
gonna give up your family life are you
going to give up you know
quality time whatever you need right
or the money you could not make as much
money as someone else um and so i think
that's what people forget it's not
as easy you can't just make all this
money up front without
consequences so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]
you